i want to start with congratulations
i've seen the first five episodes of the
new season it's fantastic fans are going
to love it um
thank you
what was it like actually if you guys
reading the scripts for the first time
because the scale and scope of this
season is like massive
i mean
we weren't really that surprised because
the duffer brothers always bring it more
and more each as each season goes so i
don't think we were that surprised um
but watching it is a different thing
than reading it because reading it
you're like okay that sounds intense and
then watching it you're like oh my like
it's so so different when you actually
like see it come together yeah i think
that is more like
that that kind of revelation of knowing
that the scale and scope of it is so
much bigger it's more of a visual thing
for me um rather than maybe reading it
on paper and you kind of something
interesting that i noticed like what you
don't see in the script but you see like
in
when it comes together is how they
transition between all the different
stories and different places and they do
it so cleverly i know i know like people
it's just so i love i know exactly what
you're talking about too yeah i i love
that that some of those transitions from
the music in episode one there's this
amazing transition of me
and then sadie and i just love it like
it's a really cool shot yeah
they're kind of talented the filmmaker
filmmaking yeah they're somewhat they're
somewhat
you know kind of i'm i'm so curious
though for you guys because stranger
things has been such a huge part of your
lives for so long and you're you're kind
of in the end game now in terms of you
know there's one more season of filming
um
has it sort of hit you a little bit that
like you're nearing the end have you
thought about that at all i mean it's
definitely something that we're we're
we're rejecting to accept we're we're
not ready for it just yet and i think
we've said this before but we we're the
last persons to accept that you can talk
to anyone before us
we we are not ready for it
it's going to be a hard goodbye when it
comes but
i think we'll always be in each other's
lives and always keep in touch and
yeah this show will obviously have a
very important kind of stamp on all of
our lives
matt and ross told me that episode 7 and
episode 9 of this upcoming season uh are
like movies in terms of the length yeah
and and how much story and how much is
sort of revealed um for do you guys
think at the end of the season spoiler
free of course that fans are going to be
yelling at the television or accepting
do you know what i mean because it
sounds like that finale is going to be
massive
no i think maybe
maybe yelling
maybe yelling i think you're going to
yell but not too loudly i don't like
yelling yeah
i don't i think uh you guys are going to
be yelling for sure it's a it's a wild
ending for sure when you think back on
the four seasons is there a shot or
sequence that uh still gives you
nightmares in terms of the challenges as
an actor trying to pull it off oh yeah
there's a scene an episode sorry there's
this um in season three
there's um
a shot of me falling through the dream
sequence uh i'm going through deca sorry
i'm going through billy's
uh memories and uh it was a dream
sequence and i'm doing like a falling
shot and it's a really cool shot but i
had to be on this insane like
kind of like lift
you know like the baby things where
people they bounce like a bit you know
like in those little baby toys that's
what i was in but like
really high up in the air and i just had
to keep spinning and i just kept
vomiting
so i think every time i watch that in
season three i get like nauseous again
um so that's that physically it was so
unbelievably challenging for me um
yeah really nauseating
um i think for me
oh so many i mean i think
in season two when i when i was there
was one scene just like at the end when
they were getting the monster out of me
and it was like the exorcism scene and i
was just screaming like all night and it
was so demanding because it was like
there were so many angles and shots that
they had to do and for each shot like
you have to give your all you can't like
half ass a shot so there's every
different angle and every different shot
is just constant screaming and and
everything and it was like all the way
up until like six in the morning of like
it's just so much and everybody it's
and then oh my god it was just so
demanding and i
it was it turned out well but
you don't need to do it again no
thank you so much for your time and
seriously congrats on a great season
thank you so much